weakened by the resignations of two of
his most senior colleagues the question
dominating westminster and filling the
front pages this morning can the prime
minister cling on to power
glum faces at yesterday's cabinet in the
hours before the resignations
later today boris johnson faces prime
minister's questions and a grilling from
mps on the liaison committee
and while he moved quickly last night to
fill his cabinet vacancies with the
appointment of nadim zahawi as his new
chancellor a man himself tipped as a
possible leadership rival and chief of
staff steve barkley as health secretary
it's clear the prime minister is
battling to survive
the resignations came just as boris
johnson was apologizing for appointing
chris pincher as deputy chief whip
despite accusations of sexual harassment
boris johnson acknowledged he had been
told about a previous complaint
following days of denials from number 10
that that had been the case
in hindsight it was the wrong thing to
do i apologize to everybody who's been
badly affected
by it i'm just going to spend some time
with my family thank you for coming
sajid javid was the first to resign
making his position clear in a letter to
the prime minister saying the tone you
set as leader and the values you
represent reflect on your colleagues
your party and ultimately the country
minutes later another body blow for the
prime minister as chancellor rishi sunak
quit too
he said the public rightly expect
government to be conducted properly
competently and seriously i recognize
this may be my last ministerial job but
i believe these standards are worth
fighting for and that is why i'm
resigning
within the conservative party anger and
our knees has reached new levels in the
past few days
we can't go on like this
and i think that's going to be a matter
for all of my colleagues those in
government and those on the back benches
about what steps we now need to take to
deal with it
labour say mr johnson's time is up and
are calling for an election now
changing one man at the top of the tory
party won't make any difference he won't
fix the problems let's have a fresh
start for britain let's have a real
change of government last month boris
johnson narrowly survived a vote of
confidence in his leadership
technically he's immune from another
such challenge for a year but tory
rebels could try and use elections to
the 1922 committee of tory back benches
to change the rules tamara cohen sky
news westminster